welcome back okay we're talking about
machine learning control and in
particular the first sequence of video
lectures we're going to be talking about
using evolutionary algorithms and
genetic algorithms for designing good
effective control laws okay I'm going to
start off simple with the genetic
algorithm then we're gonna jump into
genetic programming and we're going to
show how you can apply this for both
controlling simple systems and
controlling very complex systems okay so
evolutionary algorithms are are based on
this kind of biological principle of
natural selection so you have this this
population of control laws you start
with an initial population or generation
of control laws you let them all compete
you see how effective they all are you
essentially rate them based on their
fitness or how good or bad lis they
optimize your objective function and
then there are some genetic operations
so that that generation the effective
control us from that generation can
somehow breed more effective control
laws in the next generation so there's
this idea of natural selection of
mutations and evolution and of kind of
coding up the information that makes the
control law effective so that you can
swap and tune and modify that
information so I'm gonna walk you
through this starting with a genetic
algorithm here's kind of the big picture
view of genetic algorithms we're going
to walk through this you have some
generation of control laws which are
parametrized by a sequence of number
numbers each of those has some
performance on a cost function which
gives them an associated fitness which
is also related to their probability of
selection there are some genetic
operations here that give rise to my
future generations and the idea is that
this is a targeted optimization that
selectively improves from generation to
generation to get more and more
effective control laws now I'm going to
illustrate this on the simple case of
using a genetic algorithm to tune a PID
controller here
I would definitely caution you you
should not be tuning PID controllers in
genetic algorithms in most cases there
are far simpler ways to do this
this is an illustration of how you could
use a genetic algorithm in a system
where we kind of know the answer and we
know how it behaves and then you could
generalize that's much more complicated
control systems so this is an analogy
I'm not saying you should tune PID
controllers with genetic algorithms but
I'm going to walk through how you use
genetic algorithms on this example so if
I have a PID controller for some system
basically I have some reference value
and some measurement Y and the PID
controller breaks this up into some kind
of ok so you have this error signal
which is the difference between where I
want to be and where I am and you want
to make that error signal as small as
possible as fast as possible with out a
lot of overshoot and ringing and stuff
like that so the first line of attack is
just if I have a big error multiply it
by a number a proportional gain and feed
that into the system so if I have a big
error I get a larger control signal that
brings me closer and closer the other
thing I can do is I can integrate up
that error so if I've had a lot of error
for a long time my control gets more
aggressive and I can also have a
derivative of that error so if I have a
big jump in error my control can respond
much more rapidly to those those fast
rises in error so simple PID controller
you know this is old old technology
we've played around with before what we
can do now is use a genetic algorithm to
tune this PID control off for some
high-level objective and so what the
genetic algorithm does is it assumes a
structure for your control law in this
case we have locked in we've hard-coded
the PID structure this topology here and
we've made it so that there are three
numbers that we get to optimize KP ki
and KD these these proportional integral
and derivative gain gains okay and
that's all that genetic algorithms knows
about is that there are these three
numbers that it gets to to tune to get
better performance and so the first step
in a genetic algorithm once you have the
structure locked in is to somehow turn
those numbers into like a genetic
sequence this is supposed to mirror DNA
the DNA of the controller now and here
I'm oversimplifying this in two bits
these kind of three bit represent
of kpk i and KD just for pictorial
purposes so each of these has three
numbers associated with them and I get
to tune those sequences to get you know
bigger KP or smaller KP bigger ki or
smaller ki and so on and so forth and so
there's essentially this large parameter
cube that you're working with in this
case for these three parameters I get a
cube and what I'm trying to do what I've
plotted here in color is essentially my
cost function my objective function
which I haven't defined here but we'll
define that later I have some objective
function landscape and what I'm trying
to do is optimize it for these bright
hotspots where the parameters are really
really good to get the best performance
and I want to stay away from these kind
of red and dark spots where I get really
really bad objective performance and so
this genetic algorithm is essentially
going to be sampling this high
dimensional space trying to hone in on
these bright patches of good parameter
values to optimize the system
performance what's nice about genetic
algorithms is that these scale pretty
well to very high dimensional search
spaces so one strategy would be
something like a Monte Carlo search if I
have a 10 dimensional space I could just
randomly randomly sample and try to find
these these these hot spots but as the
system scales that becomes less and less
feasible you get the curse of
dimensionality and the volume of this
gets so large that the probability of
you just randomly finding these hot
spots becomes vanishingly small genetic
algorithms is a little bit smarter it
starts off with an initial population
which is kind of a Monte Carlo sample
but then if it if it gets near a hot
spot it kind of you know optimizes
around and finds kind of the peak of
that hot spot and it also spends more
energy exploring the hot spot regions
that it finds after the initial search
so I'll walk you through what that means
in a little bit but basically genetic
algorithms is are a set of optimization
techniques for high dimensional search
spaces of parameters once you've had a
locked structure so we lock in the
structure we define a set of parameters
we're trying to optimize that defines a
high dimensional cost landscape and the
genetic algorithm is a way of
essentially fine
these hotspots of best performance in a
way that's faster than just a brute
force Monte Carlo search okay so I want
to walk you through this this genetic
algorithm diagram here on this
particular example and then next time
we'll code this up in MATLAB and see how
it works
okay so again in this example PID
controller I had three parameters which
gives me this kind of cube every point
can be defined as this these kind of
nine bit number and what I would do is I
would start out with a generation of
candidate control laws and maybe I would
I would initialize this randomly I just
randomly generate I don't know ten
candidate control laws and the size of
this population could be bigger or
smaller depending on how expensive
expensive it is to try these control
laws so in this case I have ten
candidate control laws I chose randomly
what I would then do is I would actually
run my physical system or my simulation
with each of these control laws and I'd
run it and see how they actually perform
I basically measure you know what is the
intensity of that particular grid cell
of parameter values is it really really
dark low performance or is it really
really bright high performance and then
what I would get so I had that that kind
of initial generation and I would sort
them by their performance on this cost
function so in this case I'm trying to
minimize my cost because you know I want
small cost and so here I've sorted all
of my initial generation by cost
function so this is somehow the best
performing control law and this is the
worst performing control law so now what
the genetic algorithm does is it
essentially uses these cost functions
that performance the fitness to
determine the probability of each of
these control laws advancing to the next
generation okay so these are going to
kind of breed in some weird way and I
want the most effective control laws to
be more expressed in the next
generations genetic pool than these
least effective control laws and so
based on this probability of selection
essentially there are a number of these
genetic operations I get to choose from
and I'm just going to walk you through
kind of the simplest for but there are
modifications to these so the first one
is called elitism and you don't always
have to include the
but but sometimes it's good if you have
a good control law maybe just copy it
directly over to the next generation
because I don't want to lose this
control law you know randomly get worse
over time so maybe you'll do this
elitism and copy it over and that will
just be hard-coded I always copy the
best one or two over the next kind of
step we could do is replication so it's
very much like elitism but it's random
so I may or may not decide to replicate
and I may or may not decide to replicate
any of these based on a coin flip
probability so however unlikely it is I
might actually replicate this bad one
but it's unlikely okay
the other genetic operations crossover
is kind of like like sexual reproduction
so you basically take two to
high-performing control laws in this
case that's these guys and I will
randomly select different portions it's
hard to see there's a blue circle here
and a red circle so we've randomly
selected those snippets of kind of
controlled DNA and we're going to swap
them in the future generations
so in this crossover you essentially
swap some DNA and you get two new
control laws and so you're essentially
trying to take you know the best parts
of both control laws and figure out you
know it may be this control law was good
because of one part and this control law
was good because of another part and if
I swap them I can get a child who is
good in both aspects okay that's this
kind of crossover and then finally I
have mutation which is basically I take
a control law and I pick some some
portion of this genetic sequence and I
just randomly changed those values so
those are the basic genetic operations
we have to work with the way we actually
do this the way you actually create this
this k plus 1 generation is you
essentially go down the list after after
elitism what I do is I basically flip a
coin and there's some mixture of
probabilities maybe maybe i replicate
10% I do 50% crossover and 40% mutation
those are the rates of those genetic
operations so for each of these rows I
essentially flip a coin and decide am I
going to do a replication a crossover or
a mutation and then once I've decided
that
I flip another coin and I figure out
kind of which of these you know based on
this probability of selection which of
these individuals from generation K get
mutated crossed over or replicated over
here and so then you generate this
generation k plus 1 which somehow
statistically should be more effective
than this generation because you're
taking the best most effective
performers and mapping them over so this
is essentially a big optimization loop
to kind of iteratively generation to
generation find more and more effective
parameters for control and genetic
algorithms is not designed just for
control you can use this for any
optimization you can do this for sensor
placement and all kinds of things but
I'm just showing you how you would do
this to tune a PID controller okay what
else do I want to tell you about this so
crossover generally is more exploratory
so remember we had that cost landscape
crossover is going to try new things
that you haven't seen before no that's
wrong
sorry that's that's totally wrong
crossover is exploitative it's going to
take if you have two individuals that
are in a hot spot it's going to try to
exploit the good features and get a more
optimal solution that's closer to the
center of that hot spot whereas mutation
is exploratory mutation even if I'm near
a hot spot I might try something new and
hope that I get more optimal so mutation
serves to explore your parameter space
whereas crossover serves to exploit
things you've already found that are
successful okay so let me just say that
one more time because I said it wrong
the first time
crossover and mutation had these dual
roles these kind of complementary roles
crossover is more exploitative
so it takes known good structures and
exploits them to get even better known
structures and mutation is more Explorer
explore an explorative it explores your
parameter space more so it takes good
parameters and then it kind of mutates
them to explore other options that you
might not have seen because in lots of
these these optimization algorithms if I
find a Mac
it'll just optimize right up to the top
of that maximum and stay there
what mutation does is it allows me to
jump and maybe find a more global
maximum okay so you have these dual
roles of exploring and exploiting and
you can you can essentially change the
probability of how often I crossover
versus mutate to favor exploration or
exploitation more okay okay so that's
the overview of genetic algorithms I've
kind of motivated this on a PID control
we're going to then code this up in
MATLAB and actually see how generation
to generation those controllers get more
and more effective okay thank you